what about the USS minutes this is one
of the US's 11 aircraft carriers in
their feet it is currently stationed in
the southern South Korean Port of Busan
we've been given a rare opportunity to
come aboard to take a look at some of
the facilities and take a look at some
of the Cutting Edge hydrogens that the
team have here this is really like a
mini City this ship it uh stations some
5 000 personnel and actually it has just
returned from a mission around the South
China Sea and of course that region is
one of the hottest hot spots if you like
in terms of that big contextual issue
the rising tension with China and I had
a chance to ask Admiral Christopher
Sweeney about that issue about how much
that plays into what the U.S forces are
doing here he said his message to the
pla the Chinese Army is a very clear one
that the US will not be bullied when it
comes to this region that the U.S has
the right to sail in international
waters as international law dictates and
then it will not stand for any overtly
aggressive behavior he did make it clear
that so far his experiences that
interactions with the Chinese has been
professional and safe but other U.S
forces has previous have previously said
that that is often not the case at
raising the nervousness around the
potential for accident misstep and for
things to spiral and of course that risk
feels higher now because tensions really
are the highest they've been for many
years and while a lot of those tensions
between China and the US play out in
more covert more invisible ways some
exceptions to that of course like the
U.S spy balloon which the Chinese spy
balloon excuse me that was a big moment
and a big point of tension but this is
designed to be more overt this is
designed to be a very clear show of
strength to send a very clear message
that any escalation would have grave
grave consequences and to act as a real
deterrent because of course the key
flash point in this region is that
island of Taiwan the self-governing
island that China sees as its own that
you best message clearly that it would
come to the defense of Taiwan where
China to make any moves there and I
think that is very much a message that
the president has given and one that is
used as a deterrent here in Asia